[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 10 si no había
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa
si bien las cifras siguen en descenso
varios países de nuestro continente han
comenzado a tomar medidas para prevenir
o al menos disminuir el impacto que
pueda tener un nuevo pico de contagio
que podría comenzar entre el final de
octubre y el inicio del mes de noviembre
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
nuestro asesor científico veremos
algunas recomendaciones para prepararnos
para esta nueva ola de contagio de kobe
19 que podría impactar en el continente
americano en sólo unos minutos les
estaremos contando hablaremos también de
uruguay que aplicó un millón de dosis de
refuerzo o tercera dosis es decir que ya
el 28 por ciento de la población
uruguaya tiene ya está inyección extra
de la vacuna de facer que busca mejorar
la inmunización de los ciudadanos de
cara a la apertura de las fronteras que
está previsto para el mes de noviembre y
también para el inicio de la temporada
de verano en la que se espera que
ingrese un alto flujo de turistas a este
país suramericano tendremos reporte
desde la ciudad de punta del este en la
costa uruguaya y hablaremos también de
brasil allí pues ya superaron las
600.000 personas fallecidas por kobe y
19 por este motivo los ciudadanos
inauguraron diferentes memoriales y
también rindieron homenajes a las
víctimas mortales que ha dejado el
coronavirus en diferentes ciudades de
ese país esto mientras la campaña de
vacunación también está avanzando muy
lentamente en brasil- un poco más del 45
por ciento de los brasileños ya ha
recibido el esquema completo de la
vacunación vamos a ver las cifras en
unos minutos iremos hasta río de janeiro
para conocer los detalles de este y
otros temas relacionados con este país
pues vamos a comenzar y lo vamos a hacer
entonces con algunas de las cifras para
ver cómo está el panorama del avance de
la pandemia de kobe 19 pero esta vez no
vamos a ver las cifras del continente
americano sino las cifras globales
veamos entonces las cifras de casos
confirmados en todo el mundo ya supera
los
237 millones de casos confirmados
mientras que la cifra de fallecidos
supera los 4.8 millones de personas de
otra parte las dosis de vacunas que ya
han sido suministradas en todo el mundo
ya superan las 6 mil 419 millones de
dosis el porcentaje de la población
mundial que ha recibido ya el esquema
completo de vacuna supera solamente el
34 puntos 66 por ciento
vamos a conversar entonces con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
y asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta doctor bienvenido como siempre
un gusto saludarlo el para hablar con
usted aquí de diferentes temas en el
programa y lo estaba mencionando en la
introducción nos tenemos que preparar
para un posible nuevo pico de contagio
en el continente americano y que podemos
hacer para empezar a cuidarnos desde ya
para empezar a prevenir antes de que
esto llegue porque es mejor prevenir que
tener que estar haciéndole frente
entonces a este pico
sí definitivamente santiago si va a
haber un incremento de aceleración de
casos pero lo más importante es que si
aceleramos los procesos de vacunación y
mantenemos el distanciamiento físico
como lo hemos hecho en este tiempo y la
pedagogía acerca de los espacios
ventilados del uso correcto de las
medidas de seguridad seguramente el
impacto va a ser mucho menor que las
olas precedentes y recordemos que esto
ya no depende del virus sino del
comportamiento humano y creo que durante
este año y medio hemos aprendido varias
cosas para que mitigar que sea el efecto
tan grande para esta próxima ola que se
acerca en las en las próximas semanas
doctor hablemos ahora de la vacuna de la
farmacéutica johnson y johnson esta
compañía va a pedir la autorización ante
las autoridades de eeuu para
suministrarla como en dos dosis
recordemos que la vacuna de johnson y
johnson era monodosis y si la obtiene
sería entonces la primera vacuna que no
es de aire n mensajero que recibiría
entonces esta posibilidad de ser y no
culé inoculada en dos dosis o entero
como una tercera dosis una persona tiene
dos dosis previas de otra vacuna
diferente es decir hacer una mezcla de
vacunas esto abre puertas entonces
ampliar aún más la vacunación a nivel
internacional
es súper importante precisar algunas
cosas santiago esta vacuna es muy segura
como monodosis lo que demostró el
estudio ensemble 2 es que aplicar la
vacuna tres meses después generar
anticuerpos en un 97% que protegen de
enfermedad grave es decir que esta
vacuna como las otras vacunas al retener
un refuerzo incrementa su capacidad para
responder ante la enfermedad esta vacuna
de cáncer es de vectores virales como la
sonda de astra se pica y la sputnik y
esta vacuna estas dos anteriores que
mencioné tienen dos dosis esta entraría
a ser nuevamente otra vacuna de tres
virales con 2 12 y es probable que
muchas de las vacunas que tenemos
disponibles vayan a estar refuerzo en el
futuro para toda la población
doctor hago la aclaración cuando me
refería que esta es la vacuna que no es
de aire n mensajero que sería autorizada
para ser utilizada en dos dosis que
tendría la misma eficacia de las vacunas
que si son de aire en el mensajero hago
esa aclaración
hablemos ahora de astrazéneca esta
farmacéutica presentó también ante la fd
a una autorización para el uso de
emergencia de una terapia con
anticuerpos para prevenir el kobe 19 en
qué consistiría esta supuesta terapia y
qué referencias hay que se comenta al
respecto en el mundo médico y científico
es una noticia muy importante cuando hay
inmunización hay dos tipos de
inmunización de inmunización que se
llama viva son las vacunas estimulamos
el sistema inmune y la inmunidad pasiva
es que le damos defensas a la persona
para que se pueda defender estos
anticuerpos monoclonales y hasta esta
técnica presentó su estudio hay otras de
otras casas farmacéuticas en donde es un
se le administra personas que tienen
enfermedad tienen problemas de sus
defensas y se les regala a través del
medicamento defensas para que se puedan
proteger esta es una estrategia muy
importante en pacientes como
trasplantados pacientes con cáncer o
quimioterapia y seguramente evitaría las
complicaciones que ellos de la
enfermedad ellos reciban esta es una
gran noticia porque ya tendríamos
medicamentos antivirales anticuerpos
profilácticos y vacunas están cumpliendo
el rompecabezas para eliminar la
pandemia de la humanidad precisamente
hablando de las pastillas antivirales la
farmacéutica pfiezer lo estamos
mencionando la semana pasada esta semana
la noticia es por parte de la farmacia y
comerc que podría ser el primer
tratamiento no hospitalario aprobado por
la fda para hacer frente al kobe 19 esto
como que andaría entonces la lucha
contra el coronavirus partiendo de este
punto que usted no mencionaba de todas
las opciones que tenemos ya disponibles
para poder hacer frente al corona virus
estas dos estrategias de medicamentos
tanto la de fallecer como la marcha del
fandom son estrategias que previenen la
hospitalización y como consecuencia
previenen el fallecimiento son terapias
orales te colocan al inicio de los de
los síntomas y yo gula le informa la
infección en una forma muy rápida y
eficaz con pocos efectos adversos
esto sería uno de los complementos
perfectos porque tendríamos tratamientos
efectivos y preventivos y con eso
impediría mos que haya colapso
hospitalario y que ésta es una
enfermedad respiratoria más realmente
todas estas dos semanas han sido llenas
de buenas noticias y se avisora que
depende también de nuestro
comportamiento una modificación en el
coaching del futuro en el futuro próximo
doctor pérez muchas gracias por haber
explicado a nosotros y también a la
audiencia de france 24 estas buenas
noticias que tenemos esta semana
esperemos que todo esto empiece ya a
distribuirse a nivel internacional y
tenga las autorizaciones pertinentes
para comenzar sus distribuciones muchas
gracias doctor vamos a cambiar de tema
bueno pues ya lo estábamos mencionando
que la farmacéutica pfiezer bayern texto
formalmente la autorización para el uso
de emergencia de su vacuna contra el cob
y 19 en menores de edad comprendidas
entre los 5 y los 11 años de edad sólo
para eeuu dicha vacuna está ya aprobada
para ser usada en los jóvenes mayores de
12 años de ser aprobado su uso cerca de
2000 menores de edad podrían ser
vacunados en los próximos meses en eeuu
28 millones es la cifra de niños entre 5
y 11 años que podrían ser aptos para
vacunarse en eeuu pai sorbió ente que
espera que el regulador federal
estadounidense así lo apruebe esta
franja de edad recibiría una dosis
adaptada con 10 microgramos por cada
inyección frente a los 30 microgramos
utilizados a partir de los 12 años
sebastián de 8 años participó en el
ensayo clínico the fighter iv exm
ibérica
[Música]
me hace muy feliz ayudar a otros niños a
vacunarse
y sinceramente si tuviera que volver a
vacunar me lo haría
el suero de país de ardiente ex sería la
primera vacuna autorizada para menores
de 12 años en eeuu la meta de esta nueva
autorización sería bajar las cifras de
contagio de los niños estadounidenses
mientras las escuelas funcionan de nuevo
y llega el tiempo frío al 30 de
septiembre casi 59 millones de niños han
dado positivo en las pruebas de kobe 19
desde el inicio de la pandemia el número
de nuevos casos de comida en niños sigue
siendo excepcionalmente alto miles de
niños han pasado por el hospital y
aproximadamente 500 menores de 18 años
han fallecido en eeuu sin embargo rara
vez se enferman gravemente del cobi 19 y
el objetivo de la vacuna sería evitar
que contagien a los adultos
cada tres semanas el reino unido- hace
una revisión de la lista roja de países
que tienen restricciones debido a la
situación epidemiológica en su más
reciente revisión el estado retiró una
buena parte de los países de la
comunidad internacional sin embargo hay
siete países latinoamericanos que
todavía tendrán restricciones para que
sus ciudadanos ingresen al reino unido-
siendo estos entonces colombia ecuador
haití república dominicana panamá perú y
venezuela
vamos ahora con noticias destacadas
desde uruguay a lo largo de esta semana
este país ya vacuno con una tercera
dosis o dosis de refuerzo a un millón de
personas en este país y su gestión de la
pandemia también ha sido elogiada por el
fondo monetario internacional vamos a
conocer más detalles con cary nada más
desde la ciudad de punta del este en la
costa uruguaya hola karina hablemos
primero de ese elogio que le han hecho a
las autoridades uruguayas por farc por
parte del fmi por el manejo que le han
dado a la crisis que desató la pandemia
de kobe 19 allí
los técnicos del fondo
monetariointernacional
elogiaron el manejo de la macroeconomía
uruguaya durante la crisis
específicamente sobre señalaron la
prudencia en el manejo de la economía
destacaron que el 77 por ciento de la
población ya ha recibido
vacunación señalaron esto como un
indicio para una reactivación
económica de hecho señalaron que las
proyecciones para el crecimiento
económico del país las proyectan en un
32 por ciento para finales del 2021 por
encima del 3% proyectado en el mes de
mayo señalaron una inflación
para el final del año también de 72 por
ciento y de 58 para el final de
probablemente consideraron el hecho de
la reapertura de las fronteras y la
llegada de turistas a una industria que
afecta muchísimo la me ha llegando a
hacer parte del 6% del pib de uruguay
también destacaron en la política
económica de uruguay en cuanto a salir a
buscar nuevos mercados también vieron
con buenos ojos la política de
combustibles el cambio en el manera de
manejar los precios señalaron también
sin embargo que les preocupa el bajo
nivel educativo y que esto lleva a
grandes índices de desocupación juvenil
y afecta directamente el capital humano
del país
bueno karina tal vez esa es la noticia
más reciente hay en uruguay pero la
noticia más destacada de esta semana es
ese millón de personas que ya recibieron
la tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo
avanzado rápidamente entonces la
vacunación hay en uruguay en cuanto a
esta fase de la dosis de refuerzo
más de un millón de personas se
recibieron una tercera dosis de vacuna
contra el cob y 19 en uruguay y en este
caso del laboratorio facer lo que
equivale al 28.5 por ciento de la
población las autoridades sanitarias
tomaron la decisión luego que ingresar a
la variante delta a el país y que
también éstas contaban con stock de
vacunas dentro de uruguay primero se le
otorgó la posibilidad a las personas
inmunodeprimidas y luego se extendió a
todas aquellas personas que lo requieran
esto contrario a la solicitud de la
organización mundial de la salud que
pidió que primero se otorgarán vacunas a
el resto de los países que no han
alcanzado más del 10 por ciento de la
vacunación sin embargo uruguay decidió
mantener con este plan de vacunación y
hoy es el segundo país en el mundo en
otorgar la cantidad en el alcance de
personas con una tercera dosis de
refuerzo en estos momentos la
penetración del codo y 19 en uruguay
viene descendiendo
karina y de cara a esa apertura de las
fronteras en uruguay y también de cara a
la llegada del verano que llegan muchos
turistas a este país el gobierno está
contemplando la posibilidad de vacunar a
extranjeros menores de 18 años
aprovechando que tienen un excedente de
vacunas que dicen al respecto sobre esta
posibilidad de este posible plan
las autoridades sanitarias
indicaron que luego de que la mayoría de
la población haya recibido esta tercer
dosis de refuerzo de vacuna contra el
cob y 19 están pensando en administrarla
a los adolescentes extranjeros que
ingresen al país recordemos una vez más
el primero de noviembre se abren las
fronteras para los turistas en uruguay
las autoridades sanitarias indicaron que
si realizaron un cambio para los
adolescentes extranjeros esto quiere
decir que aquellos que ingresen al país
con un pcr negativo ya no se les pedirá
a los no vacunados que también realicen
una cuarentena las autoridades
sanitarias indicaron que la medida la
cambiaron debido a estudios
internacionales que señalan que los
menores transmiten menos la enfermedad y
cuando la transitan lo hacen con casos
gracias karina por este reporte desde la
ciudad de punta del este nos vamos ahora
a bolivia allí los ciudadanos mayores de
50 años ya comenzaron a retirar parte de
sus pensiones en un esfuerzo por hacer
frente a la crisis económica provocada
por el kobe 19 esta medida que según el
ministerio de economía beneficiará a un
millón 400 mil personas desempleadas
deja muchas preguntas sobre el futuro a
mediano plazo de estos ciudadanos veamos
esta semana los bolivianos que fueron
duramente golpeados en su bolsillo por
la pandemia pudieron empezar a retirar
parte o la totalidad de sus aportes para
la jubilación pero frente a las
administradoras de fondos de pensiones
la confusión reinaba la información es
la que no da se debe decir o no si
tienes rendimientos digamos ésta cobra
tantos en el banco y no cuidado que esté
cobrando tanto también no ve tras varias
protestas con ese reclamo el gobierno de
luis arce promulgó en septiembre una ley
que permite el retiro total o parcial de
los aportes de jubilación para los que
no reciban un salario o que estén
desempleados
el primer mandatario sin embargo invitó
a los ciudadanos a meditar si de verdad
necesitan efectuar este retiro para que
no se queden sin ahorros para la vejez
pero para los que perdieron sus empleos
con la pandemia y acabaron con sus
ahorros para sobrevivir esa norma era
más que urgente
1 cuando cuando recoge el dinero es
porque necesita no es porque porque
quiere uno en concreto los mayores de 50
años que tengan menos de 1.400 dólares
pueden retirar la totalidad de sus
recursos y quienes tengan hasta 14 mil
300 dólares podrán acceder al 15 por
ciento de su ahorro mientras que los que
tengan ahorrado más de ese valor podrán
sacar un máximo de 2 mil 100 dólares
la iniciativa no es nueva en la región
donde más de 22 millones de personas
cayeron en la pobreza en 2020 según la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe así en un esfuerzo por
impulsar su economía si le permitió en
mayo una nueva retirada de las pensiones
de sus ciudadanos la tercera desde el
inicio de la pandemia
hay diferentes variantes circulando en
nuestro continente veamos un grupo de
países al azar para ver cuáles son las
variantes predominantes en esos
territorios vamos a comenzar en el norte
canadá allí el 100 por ciento de los
casos registrados en las últimas dos
semanas corresponden a la variante delta
en brásil delta representa el 93% de los
casos mientras que gamma representa el
7.5 por ciento en costa rica la variante
delta sería el 70 punto 19 por ciento de
los casos gamma el 15 punto 38 por
ciento y la variante lambda representa
el 3.85 por ciento terminamos en
paraguay en donde la variante delta
representa 93 % gamma el 4.76 por ciento
y otras variantes el 2.38 por ciento
y en la argentina está avanzando la
vacunación en diferentes sectores de la
población y si bien las restricciones
también han comenzado a ser levantadas o
por lo menos suavizadas con la llegada
de la primavera austral este país
también está atento ante la posibilidad
de un nuevo pico de contagio para
conversar sobre esta situación sanitaria
en argentina vamos a conversar con el
doctor carlos cambur jan él es médico
argentino por su apellido puedo pensar
que es también armenio se encuentra en
la ciudad de buenos aires- barillé rico
doctor cambur ya ni comienzo a
preguntarle por esa decisión de las
autoridades argentinas de darle el visto
bueno a la vacuna scinopharm para
vacunar a menores de 3 a 10 años de edad
cuál es su opinión al respecto y cómo
avanza este proceso allí bueno cómo
están gracias por este tiempo yo estoy
por supuesto muy de acuerdo con va
hablar
los niños de 3 a 11 años el punto de
vaca que en argentina se autorizó una
vacuna que se va a poner si no fuera una
china que no tiene hasta el momento
autorización por la organización mundial
de la salud y que los estudios que están
realizándose para este grupo etario
todavía están en fase 2 y la fase 3 de
título todavía no está completada y no
tenemos datos fehacientes respecto de la
efectividad la seguridad de la vacuna
por eso hay muchos pediatras y sobre
todo muchas mamás y muchas papás que
tienen muchas dudas respecto de aplicar
o no esta vacuna en una argentina que
aún se niega a tener vacunas de faisán o
vacunas americanas
doctor cambur jana argentina tal parece
que ha tenido problemas para poder
garantizar un suministro fluido de las
vacunas de las diferentes farmacéuticas
y una de las noticias destacadas esta
semana fue esa devolución de 1.3
millones de dosis del componente número
2 de la vacuna sputnik que ha sido el
instituto gamal ella el gran
proveedor de vacunas para argentina que
fue lo que sucedió en este caso porque
tuvieron que devolver esta dosis y
porque ahora están teniendo problemas
con los rusos para garantizar el
suministro
bueno fue bastante escandaloso entre la
argentina en esta semana en las
autoridades de argentina no informan el
motivo por el cual esa vacuna fueron
devueltas a rusia simplemente nos dicen
que es un problema del etiquetado pero
realmente oficialmente no hay ninguna
explicación válida para esto y aparte de
esto algunas de esas vacunas
aparentemente fueron aplicadas de modo
que hoy hay una investigación en curso
respecto de por qué estas vacunas fueron
devueltas y claramente sí
y severas dificultades en la
administración de vacunación argentina
sobre todo de segundas dosis usted
piensa en crear gentina tiene un índice
muy alto de vacunación con sputnik una
vacuna que tampoco está autorizada por
la organización mundial de la salud por
lo tanto en argentina y el argentino
tiene muchas descripciones para el
ingreso a otros países
doctor hablemos desde la parte médica
cuál es su opinión sobre el avance de la
vacunación en general de la situación
del panorama general en argentina en
cuanto a las personas hospitalizadas
contagiados fallecidos hemos visto en
las últimas semanas que las cifras han
empezado a bajar está dando un respiro a
las autoridades pero qué esperan ustedes
para el inicio del verano esperando un
repunte y otra ola de contagio que
esperan ustedes allí bueno es posible
que suceda así y hoy la argentina está
en un momento de estabilidad en cuanto
al número de contagiados y el número de
fallecidos ha descendido respecto de los
las semanas anteriores esperemos que
continúe así el riesgo de vacunación se
aceleró en el último tiempo pero recién
la argentina tiene el 50 por ciento
solamente de su población vacunada con
dos dosis y estamos viendo que terceras
dosis seguramente van a hacer falta
no creemos que de acá en adelante haya
aportes importantes como los que tuvimos
pero sin dudas la variante delta nos
acecha está circulando de manera
comunitaria y posiblemente el brote de
contagios pueda suceder y va a depender
mucho de cómo avance el plan de
vacunación para a ver cómo va a
evolucionar este núcleo de montaje que
puede suceder de acá en adelante en las
próximas semanas ojalá que la
estabilidad continúe en argentina porque
es lo que necesita esperamos esa
estabilidad para argentina doctor cambur
ya muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en france 24 haber aclarado para
nosotros este panorama mérito médico
allí en este país merci pasamos ahora a
perú para ver allí los hechos más
destacados de la semana en torno a la
pandemia de kobe 19 pero antes demos un
vistazo a las cifras en perú la cifra de
casos llega ya a los 2.1 millones de
casos confirmados los fallecidos superan
los 199 mil ya se aproximan a los
200.000 y el 35 puntos 72 por ciento de
la población tiene ya el esquema
completo de vacunación en perú la
variante delta es la mayoritaria con el
43% de los casos la variante gamma llega
al 34 punto 29 por ciento de los casos y
la variante lambda llega al 20 por
ciento de los casos
seguimos hablando de perú este país
también está teniendo dificultades para
acceder a los lotes de las vacunas y así
poder garantizar la inmunización de sus
ciudadanos vamos a conversar con
francisco zacarías allí en la ciudad de
lima en la capital francisco gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
comenzamos por el anuncio de la opc
quien dijo que no tiene previsto lotes
de vacunas para entregarle a perú a
través del mecanismo kóvacs se van a
crear entonces sin un suministro
adicional
santiago pero esperaba este año más de
13 millones de vacunas contra el cob y
19 pero el mecanismo cobas facility ha
señalado que no va a ser posible
entregar los lotes comprometidos de
astrazéneca y facer se prevé que en los
meses de noviembre diciembre se tenga
más vacunas disponibles pero va a
demorar hasta inicios del año 2022
cerrar todas las compras jarbas barbosa
subdirector de la organización
panamericana de la salud reveló que la
demora se debe a que los laboratorios
priorizan la entrega de vacunas a los
contratos bilaterales firmados con
países donde el costo es mucho más
elevado esta situación inesperada por
las autoridades sanitarias de este país
perjudica el plan de vacunación que han
venido desarrollando el gobierno se
había trazado la meta de tener al menos
al 50 por ciento de la población
vacunada y protegida con sus dos dosis
antes de la llegada de una eventual
tercera ola del cob y 19 francisco perú
al igual que argentina está teniendo
problemas con el suministro de la vacuna
sputnik de hecha en rusia tenían muchas
esperanzas los peruanos para recibirla
para darle un impulso al plan de
vacunación y tal parece que este lote de
bakú tampoco va a llegar al territorio
peruano porque
las autoridades sanitarias encendieron
la alerta al anunciar que perú no
recibirá las 20 millones de dosis de la
vacuna se es público contra el cob y 19
que fue lo que ocurrió el contrato que
firmó el gobierno del ex presidente
francisco sagasti no cumplió con los
pagos en consecuencia las empresas rusas
no están obligadas a traerlas
puntualmente pero el factor principal
según hernando es ceballos ministro de
salud de este país es que los rusos no
tienen disponible las vacunas por
dificultades de producción así las cosas
el gobierno peruano tendrá que reducir
la velocidad de la vacunación y disponer
de los últimos lotes de facer
astrazéneca y scinopharm que dispone en
sus almacenes pero centra sus
expectativas en el arribo de 8 millones
de dosis destino farm durante octubre
que tendrán que dosificarse hasta el año
2022 cuando llegarán 20 millones de
dosis de modernas y 35 millones de dosis
de facer contra el jove y 19 francisco
estaba dando algunas de las cifras del
panorama gene perú y mencionábamos que
la variante de más predominancia si es
la variante delta que dicen las
autoridades al respecto que van a hacer
para combatir porque además también hay
algunos casos de la variante delta plus
el gobierno de pedro casi ordenó que
todas las provincias de perú sean
clasificadas en el nivel de alerta
moderado se ha reducido el horario al
toque de queda ahora va de unas a las
cuatro de la mañana las actividades en
espacios cerrados sin ningún nivel de
alerta moderado centros comerciales
restaurantes supermercados entre otros
cuentan con aforos que van del 50 al 60
por ciento esta nación contabiliza más
de 2 millones 181 mil casos confirmados
y más de 199 mil 500 fallecidos por el
sars coptos y hablando de vacunación el
país se emprende la inmunización de
jóvenes de 18 a 20 años hasta el momento
pero tiene un avance del 44 por ciento
de un universo objetivo que son 28
millones de peruanos el último reporte
del ministerio de salud registró más de
12 millones 294 mil personas con dos
dosis de la vacuna contra el jove y 19
si es con muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de lima y
previamente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente comenzamos en méxico
en donde recibieron 1.5 millones de
dosis de la vacuna sputnik de rus y
suman así ocho millones cuatrocientos
mil dosis con las que han impulsado el
proceso de vacunación en ese país
mientras tanto en paraguay allí
recibieron 84 mil dosis de la vacuna a
facer para seguir avanzando con su plan
de vacunación paraguay ha concentrado el
acceso a las vacunas a través del
mecanismo kóvacs y a través de las
donaciones por parte de países como por
ejemplo eeuu y brevemente les cuento
también que las autoridades de colombia
avalaron aplicar la vacuna sinovac
desarrollada en china para los menores
de 3 a 11 años de edad una fase del plan
de vacunación que comenzará pronto a
nivel nacional
y brasil esta semana superó las 600.000
víctimas mortales por el cob y 19 una
cifra de las más altas del mundo por
este motivo hubo homenajes a las
víctimas en diferentes ciudades de ese
país y hubo también por supuesto
críticas al presidente ya el bolsón aro
que ha minimizado el impacto de la
pandemia está con nosotros valeria
saccone para profundizar en torno a este
tema a valeria comencemos por esas
600.000 muertes una cifra lamentable que
dicen las autoridades y cómo transcurren
o transcurrieron los homenajes en las
diferentes ciudades del país sobre todo
allí en río de janeiro donde usted se
encuentra
brasil es el segundo país del mundo más
afectado por la pandemia de coronavirus
en números absolutos y sólo por detrás
de los eeuu estamos en la playa de
copacabana que a mi espalda o no en ejea
organizado un homenaje a las víctimas
del corona virus 600 pañuelos blancos
que recuerdan a las 600.000 víctimas
pero en este panorama sombrío hay una
buena noticia el 58 por ciento de las
ciudades brasileñas en septiembre no
registraron ninguna muerte por el cómic
19 es el mejor dato desde mayo de 2020
estamos hablando de 3 mil 274 ciudades
también la media semanal de muertes ha
bajado se sitúa en 500 fallecimientos
diarios muy lejos de los más de 4.000
muertes registradas en abril de este año
es el claro resultado de la vacunación
que en brasil avanza a pesar de ser un
reto enorme porque brasil tiene una
población de 213 millones de habitantes
valeri hablemos ahora del plan de
vacunación el 45 por ciento de los
brasileños ya tienen el esquema completo
de vacunación que más dicen las
autoridades en torno a este plan
en brasil la vacunación avanza aunque
avanza más lentamente de lo que podría
recordamos que el país tropical ha sido
una verdadera potencia en temas de
vacunación tanto en américa latina como
en todo el mundo hubo cierto retraso al
principio del proceso con la compra de
la vacuna el gobierno no respondió a más
de 100 mensajes de la empresa fighter y
por eso está siendo investigado en la
comisión parlamentaria que lleva a cabo
al senado desde el mes de mayo también
hay que decir que de vez en cuando
grandes ciudades como río de janeiro y
sao paulo tienen que suspender la
vacunación por falta de dosis pero
también hay que decir que después de 12
días se reanuda el proceso hoy el 45% de
la población es decir 97 millones de
brasileños están totalmente inmunizados
y el 70 por ciento es decir 149 millones
de personas recibieron la primera dosis
brasil ha apostado por potenciar la
primera dosis y retrasar la segunda para
intentar contener una pandemia que
estaba haciendo estrago entre la
población y los resultados ahora saltan
a la vista
vale de que hay de las restricciones el
gobierno estaba por allí el rumor de
posiblemente levantar algunas de las
restricciones de cara al carnaval y a
las vacaciones de verano
las dos principales ciudades de brasil
el río de janeiro y sao paulo se
preparan para flexibilizar el uso de las
mascarillas el 15 de octubre no será
obligatoria en los lugares al aire libre
donde no haya aglomeraciones ampa no se
siente muy confiante porque es para
alcanzar para esta fecha del 15 de
octubre el 90 por ciento de población
totalmente inmunizada y por eso las
autoridades locales están preparando un
carnaval a lo grande sin ningún tipo de
restricción en el que se esperan 15
millones de personas durante una semana
y río de janeiro hace lo mismo el
alcalde eduardo paes esperan no
solamente celebrar el mayor carnaval de
la historia sino también la tradicional
fiesta de nochevieja que se celebra aquí
en la playa de copacabana con los
famosos fuegos artificiales
gracias valeria por este reporte es todo
por hoy en el programa nos vemos la
próxima semana siga con nosotros
[Música]